نسمع من شخص مقرب من بوتين أننا
لا نسمع كثيرًا من صديقته
وأم لأطفال متعددين
لبوتين إيلينا خبيبة ،
اللقب الرسمي للاعبة الجمباز الأولمبية السابقة هي رئيسة
المجموعة الإعلامية الوطنية الروسية التي
تعد واحدة من أكبر المؤسسات الإعلامية
في روسيا  وهي تتحدث الآن
علنًا قائلة إن الدعاية
سلاح مهم في الوقت الحالي مثل تلك
المدافع الرشاشة ،
يحتاج شعبنا إلى نجاحنا لأن
المعلومات تعمل في ظل الظروف
التي نعيشها حاليًا ونحن
نقاتل من أجل بلدنا مثل سلاح
حرب  ومن حيث الأهمية ، فهي
لا تقل قيمة عن بندقية كلاشينكوف
ولكي تكون واضحًا فإن الدعاية التي
تتحدث عنها ليست مجرد فيديو مثل
pagosian وهي تحلق بطائرة مقاتلة تتصرف
مثل كل شيء عظيم جدًا حيث
تشتعل قواته بالنار إنها خبير تلو
خبير  في التلفزيون الحكومي يقول إن
بوتين يجب أن يستخدم الأسلحة النووية قائلاً
إن هذه الحرب هي حرب روسيا ضد
النازيين وأن
الدعاية قوية وقد تم
استخدامها لتبرير غزو بوتين الكامل
لأوكرانيا ولتبرير هجماته
وسجن الأعداء السياسيين.